van damme ou bonjour
bonjour merci d'avoir accepté notre
invitation ce matin sur rtl france pour
parler de cette tension entre alger et
paris notamment après les propos d'
emmanuel macron sur la légitimité
historique des tenants du pouvoir en
algérie les propos assez fort alors
prononcé devant des étudiants il a
notamment parlé d'un discours officiels
algériens qui repose sur une haine de la
france ces propos dont qui ne sont pas
officielles et qui ont été dit devant
des étudiants est-ce qu'il relate
réellement la position officielle du
chef de l'état
je ne suis pas autorisé à dire quelle
est la position officielle du chef de
l'état c'est pas son porte parole ce
qu'on peut dire si simplement que le
président de la république à un discours
de vérité
est qu'il dit des choses que tous les
historiens savait d'ailleurs et cgc ont
été prononcées devant benjamin stora qui
était présent à cette réunion donc on
est toujours dans au fond le regard
lucide et critique porte la france son
histoire et ce regard critique et lucide
que l'algérie refuse sur son histoire
est ce que le président emmanuel macron
il change de posture parce qu'on se
souvient lui-même avait de vraies un
point un rapprochement mémorial des deux
pays l'avait aussi qualifié l'occupation
française en algérie de crimes contre
l'humanité
moi je ne pense pas qu'il change de
posture il est toujours sur ce chemin de
vérité sur cette volonté de regarder
lucidement notre histoire d'abord pour
nous mêmes pour concilier le pays les
français avec toutes ses composantes
mais il espéré j'espérais c'était quand
même le sens du rapport au toit
n'oublions pas qu'il devait y avoir
l'équivalent en algérie avec le rapport
chitti d'antan on n'a toujours pas vu le
jour
la volonté de ce rapport stora s'étaient
tous vraiment de d'essayer avec
l'algérie ensemble que chacun regarde
lucidement son histoire pour la dépasser
pour l'assumer et pour que le passé
arrête d'empoisonner le futur
quand emmanuel macron parle d'un
discours officiels algériens qui repose
sur une haine de la france à quoi pense
précisément le chef de l'état puisque ce
sont des constats sur le présent pour le
goût
mais bien sûr que c'était un constat sur
le présent mais je veux dire tout le
monde sait aujourd'hui que depuis
soixante ans le gouvernement algérien
s'est appuyée ne pouvoir a réécrit
l'histoire et l'a instrumentalisé
il se sert de cette histoire
glorifiant effectivement la guerre
d'indépendance en faisant de la france
le bouc émissaire et les causes de tous
ses maux tout simplement pour détourner
l'attention du peuple algérien pour que
celui ci ne se rendent pas compte de la
faillite du système de sa gestion
puisque ce cas un pays qui a des
ressources et un pays riche mais
une partie des gens au pouvoir s'est
accaparé et le pouvoir et les richesses
alors le 27 de 20 septembre dernier
emmanuel le maquereau avait demandé
pardon aux combattants harkis abandonnés
à leur famille qu'ils ont subi les camps
la prison le déni comment est-ce que ça
a été perçu côté algérien cette demande
de pardon est ce que là aussi ça a
suscité des tensions
n'ont pas vraiment c'était plutôt une
surprise agréable parce que finalement
la presse algérienne on a peu parlé ce
qui est logique puisque l'algérie a
toujours dit dossier a requis même
dossier franco français donc si c'est un
dossier franco français effectivement à
la france de le traiter ceci étant
si la france reconnaît effectivement eu
des manquements aux valeurs de la
république si elle reconnaît la banque
dans le des harkis il faudra bien que
l'algérie s'interroge sur ce que sont
devenus les personnes abandonnées et
notamment sur les massacres qui ont
suivi l'indépendance algérienne
est là aussi l'algérie ne reconnaît rien
ce qu'il faut voir c'est vraiment c'est
que
dissymétrie autres la france l'algérie
entre le président bak rock et les
gouvernants algériens dont une partie
d'entre eux puisque d'un côté on a un
président qui a le courage et
l'honnêteté de reconnaître un certain
nombre de faits historiques et de
l'autre côté il n'y a pas de retour à la
proche des 60 ans de la fin de la guerre
d'algérie justement
l'accession à son indépendance est ce
que et bien les tensions pourraient être
davantage ce sera 10 et
je sais pas et je pense très honnêtement
que c'est pas si grave que ça parce que
d'abord d'autres tensions on en a eu il
faut pas oublier qu'en 2000 le président
bouteflika en visite officielle sur une
télévision publique française avait
insulté les harkis il faut pas oublier
que il y avait eu on avait rappelé aussi
le
l'ambassadeur algérien je pense parce
qu'il y avait eu des émissions sur les
chaînes publiques françaises sur le
mouvement l'irak qui conteste ce qu'on
veut pouvoir algérien voilà donc il ya
des crises qui est intéressant c'est
quand même de voir que assez souvent
seriez à se passer à cette colonisation
et sept gars de l'algérie
et parce que et c'est bien ce que dit
effectivement le doute le président
macro et qui gênent mais ce que disent
tous les historiens c'est à dire que le
gouvernement algérien actuel du moins
une frange des gens qui sont au pouvoir
refuse toujours ce regard critique et
elle continue d' instrumentaliser
l'histoire il faut vraiment que il
arriva à accepter cette histoire avec
ses six essais lumière et puis que l'on
puisse aller de l'avant parce
qu'aujourd'hui ce soit les français que
ce soit le peuple algérien que ce soit
les harkis que ce soit les pieds noirs
voilà je crois que tout le monde envie
d'aller vers de l'apaisement et vert à
la construction de relations fructueuses
et non pas de rester toujours dans le
ressentiment et dans le monde ce projet
historique
comment en quelques mots pour conclure
par quoi pourrait passer cet apaisement
des relations aujourd'hui
je crois que la france a fait beaucoup
de gestes maintenant c'est à l'algérie
d'en faire il faut que l'algérie
reconnaissent elles aussi
elle a commis des erreurs vis-à vis à
vis à vis de la population algérienne
vis-à-vis des messalistes la guerre
d'algérie reconnaissent qu effectivement
évidemment que la colonisation le
système pour le miel un système est un
système qui les domine un peuple qui
l'oppriment très bien mais il y a aussi
dans les colonisations de peuplement des
apports et en se souviennent qu'en 2005
quand on avait voulu dire qu'il y avait
eu aussi des apports positifs
ça avait créé là aussi des tensions
entre la france et l'algérie donc
vraiment je crois qu'il faut maintenant
prendre comprennent que les nouvelles
générations
elles veulent aller vers l'avant elles
veulent pas être prisonnier de ce passé
et surtout de sa réécriture merci
beaucoup mende à momo d'avoir accepté
notre invitation ce matin sur rtl france
je le rappelle vous êtes professeur de
sociologie président de l'association
agir pour les harkis